a recent Reuters Ipsos poll showed that
Democrats actually losing ground with
Millennials they still don't like
Republicans certainly not in some kind
of significant majority but they don't
support Democrats and that's a huge
shift for people under 30 the transition
from from sort of young liberal to old
or conservative leads one to an
undeniable and repeatedly observable
fact which is why I think the people
across the board could at least see a
silver lining in this conservatives in
general are happier in May and looking
at the statistics I mean if if if you
young progressives could only know now
what you'll know then
[Music]
Oh grandness a left hand all these words
thought he was a toxic man taught me in
worldly ways it'll show you and it'll
beat you before you even know the truth
is blind and you soon will find that you
don't even know I wish then I knew I
don't know now when I was younger a wish
then I knew I don't know now but I was
dumb the taxman such a greedy blow feel
you go away your paychecks cut in half
again I'll give him to the state to come
on strong it ain't too long forward
spent on useless crap they'll rob you
blind and you soon will find that you
were raped again
[Applause]
[Music]
when a vbt and say yeah P cuz the guy
slept on some tits your preferred
pronouns Ozzy Renzi and no one gives a
[ __ ]
Oh young grandson there's nothing I can
say that's how you learn that y'all
right there and that's the hardest way
[Music]
subscribe watch one of these other
videos or hit the notification Bell well
you should hit that if you subscribe
anyways because subscriptions don't mean
anything on you to anymore now you have
to get notifications that it shows up in
your inbox so I don't know why you
subscribe in the first place but that's
we have to do also making money off
these videos anymore because YouTube
decided why they just said we're not
going to and when we said why they
didn't tell us why exactly imagine if
you should up to your job do your work
and then they said hey by the way we're
not gonna pay you said why they said
piss off